Двадцять вісім років минуло після падіння Берлінського муру.
Втім, останні вибори до Бундестагу довели:
невидимий мур між сходом та заходом Німеччини
все ще існує, принаймні у політичних поглядах.
Доказом цьому - успіх правопопулістської
партії "Альтернатива для Німеччини" у східній Німеччини,
де вона посіла друге місце.
На мапі це позначено синім кольором.
Причому найбільше за антимігрантську та антиісламську партію
проголосували в тих місцевостях, де найменша
кількість біженців. Саме тому експерти
вважають, що причина підтримки АдН на сході -
це здебільшого не ксенофобські чи неонацистські настрої,
а невдоволення східних німців своїм рівнем життя
після об'єднання Німеччини.
"Вони почуваються, так би мовити,
все ще німцями "другого класу".
Я думаю, багато східних німців вважають, що їх ще
повністю не прийняли у німецьке суспільство.
Також багато з них розчаровані тим, що обіцянки,
які їм давалися у дев"яностому році,
під час об'єднання, по-справжньому
не були виконані."
Раніше такі настрої на сході країни активно поширювала партія Ліві,
нащадок соцпартії НДР,
позиціонуючи себе як протестна партія і голос
розчарованих німців. Тепер все змінилося.
Частина електорату Лівих перейшла на бік АдН,
і тепер вже "Альтернатива" стає новою партією протесту
для східної Німеччини. Відтік населення зі Сходу
на Захід, деіндустріалізація та економічний
занепад на сході лише грають на руку АдН.
Ще одна важлива причина –це наслідки НДР.
"Це іронія долі. Країна була розділеною
протягом 40 років. Тепер ми наближаємося
до тридцятиріччя об"єднання,
яке буде за три роки. І розрив
між східною та західною Німеччиною нині здається
глибшим, ніж будь-коли.
Саме тому в мене складається враження,
що пост-ендеерівський період буде довшим,
ніж тривалість існування, власне, НДР."
На думку експертів, знадобиться багато років
і кілька поколінь,
щоб невідповідності між сходом і заходом Німеччини зникли.
А водночас важливо не ігнорувати появу
дедалі більшої кількості правих рухів та організацій
на сході країни,
подекуди з неонацистськими гаслами.